alright as an actor how much should
perform a study the entire script before
shooting or just focus on their own
parts you can only keep it true to life
unless you know the whole story and you
live it and you're part of it
no you would study the script to
understand the tone my child of feeling
the other characters as well as your own
hi Yeah right how many times would you
normally digest a script before you
would actually get on set depends on how
tough it is really yeah well yeah
nothing apart right yes and you are here
tonight at the 28th annual script reward
and you're being honored your monday no
no our mother is being honored she
passed away in the fall and she was one
she and Glen's sonnenberg created the
script reward and she was a part of it
every year until you know the last I
don't know five six years and you
remember hearing her speak in the
beginning starting it and so for
enthusiasm at home yeah we I mean they
had regular meetings for descriptor yeah
we want to yeah she loved it it was a
very creative thing to her and it was
very important to her she felt it had
strong value and literature and great
riding
and she was very dedicated to helping
the library and to what the script
reward meant but so many times
screenwriters are given the least sort
of credibility in terms of a film why
did she feel that this aspect is so
important well I don't know that I agree
with you this they may not be the famous
faces in front of the camera but we say
in the industry without a good script
you have nothing and when a film doesn't
work you can usually suspect the
material wasn't good enough you had a
message to your mother tonight what
would it be
that we're proud of her and we're proud
to represent her legacy will reduce a
girl yes he's she was a stellar lady and
the library meant a great deal to her
and this was one of her this whole
concept with one of her ways of creating
a event that would support continually
the library was financially and we you
know public relations
for sure yes absolutely do you feel that
she's with you tonight in spirit oh
absolutely yeah he's been with us a lot